welcome everyone this is the first
screencast in our series on methods and
metrics fundamentally what we're trying
to do with this unit is give you help
with your projects and specifically
give you help with the experimental
aspects of your project and so the kind
of highlight topics for us will be
around things like managing your data
set for the purposes of conducting
experiments
establishing baseline systems and in
turn doing model comparisons between
baselines and an original system or
between an original system and published
results in the literature and so forth
and relatedly we're going to give you
some advice on how to optimize your
models effectively those are kind of the
highlight topics there and i would say
that all of this is kind of oriented
toward the more abstract topic
of helping you navigate tricky
situations that arise as you conduct
experiments in nlp and as you'll see
very often these tricky situations arise
because we encounter limitations in the
data that's available to us or we're
just fundamentally constrained in terms
of computing resources
and that leads us to have to make some
compromises in the ideal experimental
protocol that we would use
these things are inevitable and the idea
here is that we're going to equip you
with some tools and techniques for
thinking about the trade-offs and making
your way through all of these tricky
situations
there are a bunch of associated
materials for these screencasts we have
a whole notebook that's on metrics i'm
going to offer some screencasts that
just highlight a few of the metrics that
are discussed in that notebook
but it's meant as a resource the
notebook itself so that you could pursue
other avenues and overall what i'm
trying to do is give you a framework for
thinking about what metrics encode in
terms of their values what bounds they
have and where they can be applied and
misapplied
scikit learn implements essentially all
of the metrics that we'll be discussing
and to their credit they've done a
wonderful job of offering rich
documentation that will again help you
not only understand what the metrics do
but also where and how they can be
effectively applied
and then there is an entire notebook
that's on methods especially
experimental methods and that covers a
lot of the tricky situations that i just
described in terms of setting up
experiments and thinking about
trade-offs and then following through on
model evaluation and so forth and that
notebook is nice as a supplement to
these screencasts because it embeds a
bunch of code that could help you run
hands-on experiments to get a feel for
the core concepts
and we have two readings resnick inland
2010 is a wonderful overview of
experimental evaluations in the context
of nlp and smith 2011 appendix b is a
compendium of different metrics so
another good resource for you if you're
unsure about how a metric works or what
it what its bounds are or how it's
calculated and things like that
the final thing i want to say for this
overview relates specifically to the
projects that you'll be pursuing
the bottom line for us is that we will
never evaluate a project based on how
good the results are
now we acknowledge that in the field and
throughout science publication venues do
this because they have additional
constraints on space nominally and that
leads them as a cultural fact about the
way science works to favor positive
evidence for new developments over
negative results i frankly think this is
unfortunate and exerts a kind of
distorting influence on the
set of publications that we all get to
study
but nonetheless that's the way the world
works at present
in the context of this course we are not
subject to that constraint so we can do
the right and good thing scientifically
of valuing positive results negative
results and everything in between
so i repeat our core value here we will
never evaluate a project based on how
good the results are instead we're going
to evaluate your project on the
appropriateness of the metrics that you
choose
the strength of your methods
and really fundamentally here the extent
to which your paper is open and
clear-sighted about the limits of its
findings so you'll notice that given
this framework here you could report
state-of-the-art results world
record-breaking results on a task but
nonetheless not succeed with the project
if it fails on all of these things that
we've listed under our true values and
conversely
you might have a hypothesis that turns
out to be a miserable failure in terms
of the performance metrics that you're
able to report but that could lead to an
outstanding grade in the context of this
course provided that you do all of these
things and that would be under the
heading of a negative result that
nonetheless teaches us something really
fundamental and important
about nlp and therefore pushes the field
forward